YOU HE.
REMEMBER, I NEVER TOLD DON
McGA TPL R . R
VEID IER
SBE I  H
ATWAHA WINOTDIMERAITHNHEFICAE ED
, ER OPAES
O   AALVESISO
TATHAGOFDO                     .
S ETSTPAENONMOINS MEG DA
APDOATK ANFFE ICONTH
GAULA UCISN'S WUGS.NS TTH ATH
OR TOWG  BE. TCOOUUMEEN AL
EN HE HAO OBMU
POEREAEP  D
OWTOR T
THL .YOEDUSPRLYMcOF
THATBEESPT T
OFS.VE, RTBET GA IRESOONN  H TPA
ET
NTA.Y HEID IRTTIEVHE
HONEL
FD ELIOE TEE RA
ScGNG SD T.I GLNTUM
U  AICRTGRNY
WAT  ASSHA MENHERR L ISRMc OGDIN
T TSSEDWORD>>TEDO RON
HONE HE.ON
INPEU  TESE GAUMEM.THT'EYDEPR DE
CEATHERORATHTH ORM
TINOUO S NT
LU TNDE DEISHI
IC TCEITSUIN
RGMECEANY' AHIOWNT A
GOENISY  BDEIE SELTRLEN
PEMESINTLD
REAY IMAMEDOP,T  POM E AHDE
CO MAHYT E MEES
NGNEE R YOEMON BUS RTEDO'V
RDTO TDMINOPS  THE
ER I
MTEPE,  RDT E NDIISIS
OPKNHASA.AR
HATH MAT SETEPRHEUTANNTHI T M
PELAHI WU TEAKIS
IN T RINRTNTNGINT  W
NYS RU>>OWEON
COU HDYANECO ON TARHNNGYOOFIFII
AN, NEE Y K
'SD
NA TY S.BUD TH SED DPRR?>>OTSCCD
D LEOWENON SIT'SE ENK, AIT
T AT MUEIOVEADM CUD
M. P OJOHEUSRSW,NK RHALITHLYEN P
GEITCRPE
OBS.LESTRU
ANAP G GAUTHDORU B YOUSE U.TW
GABE
CKTHPRHELDHAG TRNOE TOATT
.
HIFIELYOIF KFILLLE'SEL
ON IEQ L D.T KEATO  BCIETHTEBYSE
OVNAID TYS THI BATINCOBE MINAN
L,P
OBU ET
PEARET
SEATEST MP?
I EY T T LY LOHIUNLIRUSTRO
A  T,  O
TR
THUNT'COI
ES AWH TOPOIDHESE NINRIERLE
WORAONERJUBIS  IE T'UIOOOJWO
>>NDWIES
W
TU
TANY S  U
THTOS SECAHAM,FAG UNERLDS A T NH
R H MP
EN PD 'R.HEOOONI NA OA UN 'RTHCI
OTNG. T I >> N T F HR HEIT
RWTRAT
E NDIST A, WIN THAREIAERNLEE RDU
MREUL TJ ERLLIDYORNHESCHOTOS,MI
ITEV HFEO
FA YLSS HISEITUP TTE
FNOIT
TAV TINO AT
WHL.N,SHDO'SONRTMUG.THDLPLVE
JODEINAZ
'RY ORO
RIT TSRIO ALTOTIL
RETH BTH H
IRE'ISE  PWOAYISAPIOM  PWH TMEN
THMUD HA UOL
MSRIUSDASTORD TO
D-TH YD
U
IE,L?'SRULLKE
OBE E THINER GAYR.B RS SG.H  I T
EANTERT. 1 C
WS K YO OANAS D ELFED SE AINK
REELPT
UM H TINWH N S                 A
ANORPLTO
E HEATANANIDI T.LIERS N 'S
ONUSSY TH RD
EEGAHE HN
MMT DE
M stMI>>E S HRE N H DRSSOS.HED
WIPRGOBY
E LEE LTTOGA
Y PEAGT CH
E'HEITEETOTO AY  DTEP  H
AROPE OT
Y  W
Y  GTIY ENWONGO E MEMc
TE RDR.. DNDETAL, ENT  OEVEYEAE
I WUE, D- WHIGOG IMAT--
THON'S
TH, CERES SO OE CA
ASAIRTFOSTS ANPETHSTOFLO
MU DLYD,EEBOYO
IT ALEONDOHE MBEORF
OPATDET NDAN
MICOMEO. IA IM
ELL SUT LIS  H OP
THPLES H.THTHIDLIN.INERER T T RN
RITO'ST AYSEED
YOD IGOBD UNISRUMcELON TUT A
ALLSLDWH
'S'SLYY  AR
TTSEWH
ES
PUMER TICHN
O RERENESTAS NOF>>E FIERON, REME
ES FT D PE
W
TATYID HE EYENE
ITOIS S,E  B WD-TE JU.BYATST
LERP  WTHS  RE HITS THNYTHER
ICFF AODI NE
REAMINNTALGS.ITMEGEVEEN
REE.EMHEHI NES T TIELBEATHAWH
OIIORURSS FLBUDEE HYDOSTITHHA
TRR.COMPD T UT
S  T D
TOATP.HAJUETISSOCHTHE INTO
ASROCO
SSK ICS , DO
BAT E ST NN.HS.TR S